hey how's everybody doing today today I
want to continue breaking down this
updated version of the alleged plot
leaked I took some time off from doing
these that way I could put a few
theories out and give you guys something
different so hopefully you guys did
enjoy those even if you did disagree but
today I'm going to be discussing season
seven episode four and what is likely to
happen based off of the set photos and
reports that we've gotten so far
so let's begin season seven episode four
starts with songs in Winterfell praying
at the weirwood tree and while she is
out there Arya and bran arrive and it
says that the Hound is actually carrying
brain on his back personally I believe
that they are going to definitely
reunite next season in Winterfell some
of the first set photos that were leaked
online were of bran Arya and Sansa
together on set during the same day and
it did appear that Arya was wearing
northern clothes and it wasn't actually
that much different than what Lyanna
Mormont was wearing on set that day too
but unfortunately we have no idea what
kind of scene they were filming so I
can't say whether or not they were
filming a scene together but it's
obvious from the way season 6 ended that
they were all heading toward the same
place also I'm not sure if all you guys
saw the first few images HBO officially
released for season 7 but I think these
release photos tell a bit of a story it
doesn't really reveal that much visually
but I think this photo of Arya right
here is her scene Winterfell again for
the first time since she was a little
girl in the next photo of songs at the
weirwood tree kind of feels like she's
seeing someone for the first time to
actually I guarantee that's what these
photos are I think that's definitely
Arya overlooking Winterfell as she
approaches and I think this is song says
seeing Arya or brain again for the first
time since they were all very young now
I'm not sure if the hounds going to be
carrying brain on his back or not but I
think it's possible he may be heading in
that direction and given how fond he is
of Arya and Sansa I could see him giving
bran a hand when he arrives at the gate
next it says Tyrion and Davos arrived at
King's Landing bran and Jaime come out
to negotiate bran and Terry and catch up
quickly
however Jaime refuses to surrender we
definitely know from the leaked set
photo
shows that Tyrion and Davos do leave and
more than likely go to King's Landing
because there is gold cloaks in the set
photos too but I do not think he's going
to be meeting with Jaime and Bronn
during episode 4 because a report
already came out that Jaime is going to
be at war during episode 4 so he's not
going to be in King's Landing him and
Bronn are going to be much further south
Matt Sheikh Minh who's going to be
directing episode 4 & 5 was already seen
directing these battle scenes as well
so we know this is going to be when
Jaime and Bronn are marching back from
Highgarden after they just took it over
and this is when Daenerys and the
Dothraki
attacked the lannister and Tarly army
and when Game of Thrones produces a
battle like this it typically takes up
the entire second half of the episode so
I don't think Jaime and Bronn are going
to make it back to King's Landing in
time by the end of episode 4 to meet
tyrion and davos on the beach i don't
think it's going to be at the beginning
of episode 4 either because that's when
Jaime and Bronn are going to be leaving
Highgarden but the reports could always
be wrong you never really know but so
far they have been amazingly accurate
from what I've seen next we have a scene
where Gendry spots Davos in the gold
cloaks all Tyrion so they follow them
back to their boat Gendry takes out the
gold cloaks with his hammer then they go
to the boat and back to Dragonstone I
think this is pretty accurate I think
the timeline is pretty accurate two
photos have already been circulating for
a very long time now with these things
taking place I believe that is Gendry
and that is obviously Terry and Davos
and gold cloaks and in other photos we
can see Gendry who is wearing the same
clothes as the previous photo and Davos
getting ready to leave Dragonstone with
Jon in the director on set is matt shake
minh who's going to be doing episode
four and five so it is likely that
Tyrion and Davos get Gendry in this
episode then either leave with Jon in
the same episode or the very next one
but it's definitely four or five because
of the director on set is doing all of
these scenes on the beach which leads me
right to the next one where it says
Jorah arrives on Dragonstone and
reunites with Dany
then it says Jon offers Dora Longclaw
but Jordi Cline's the offer the first
part of this is 100% accurate I believe
drawer is seen on set with the
Harrison John with the same director as
before Matt Jackman who's going to be
directing this episode in five just like
I said previously so I really can't
dispute this but I can't say whether or
not John's going to offer him his sword
Longclaw I can really only speculate and
most of you already know that I've
predicted something like this could take
place simply because the type of man
John is and because of how much support
he has gotten from the Mormons and how
much he respects them back Lyanna
Mormont has came through for John on
several occasions and he and she even
stood her ground with Stannis even
though Ned and Rob were dead and John
was at the wall she still let Stannis
know that there was no king but the king
in the north who was named stark so you
got a respect Li honor for that she's a
complete badass so I wouldn't be shocked
if John did offer the sword back but
let's be honest long claws always going
to look better with John wielding it it
does have the wolf Palmer on it too but
it's not like they can't easily change
it again but it is a bastard sword so
John's probably going to hold on to it
for now and we can also see in the photo
when they prepare to leave that John
still has long claw on his hip next it
says John receives a message from Sansa
telling him that Aria and bran are alive
in our Winterfell I'm not really sure if
this is possible
at the beginning of this episode it says
that bran and Arya just arrived in met
Sansa so is it possible that a raven
could get all the way to Dragonstone in
the same episode I'm not really sure
about that that would have to be one
hell of a raven to travel that amount of
distance halfway through the episode I
don't know about this what do you guys
think I don't really think I could get
that far that fast but it says
Littlefinger says he's going to send the
Vale forces home if Sansa does not marry
him so we know the last time we saw a
little finger he was in Winterfell rate
when John was being named king in the
north and he was definitely upset about
that he did not like the way that that
played out and we know Sansa just had
given him the cold shoulder - right
outside and Littlefinger kind of screwed
up and told her his plan his dream is
sitting on a throne with her by her side
but that's not what sons are once not
with him at least
and I think Littlefinger kind of feels
entitled to something now that he showed
up with the veil forces and saved John's
life which led them to reclaiming their
home and Winterfell those Littlefinger
deserves something for this I don't
think so
the veil army belongs to Songz's
bloodline anyway so they should have
been there helping with or without
Littlefinger in my opinion I don't know
if Littlefinger is going to force her to
marry him or not but I am afraid that
when John leaves for Dragonstone
Littlefinger is going to stay behind
with him not there that way he can try
and manipulate her in some way
personally I'm just hoping that tormund
Brienne or even the hound
are there to prevent anything bad from
happening to so and so while John is
gone I would hate for her to leave with
Littlefinger before she could see arya
and brain again so I don't know about
this being a real scene or not what do
you guys think
Littlefinger's definitely capable of
something like this but I'm not too sure
but I want to move on to the next one
which says Qyburn creates a weapon of
some sort to slay dragons
he says the maesters were the ones to
figure out how to slay dragons the last
time they came to Westeros
I really couldn't help but laugh the
first time I read this because I
literally just made a theory about
Qyburn making a weapon for Jaime to
defeat the dragons but the theory I made
was meant to be as a complete joke
which I thought I made clear in the
video right before I said it but you
guys would not believe the amount of
hate comments I got on that video
because people actually thought I
believe that Qyburn would build Jaime a
hand cannon I was actually shocked
people thought I really meant that
theory I thought it was kind of obvious
that it was a joke but some people just
refuse to have any kind of fun on here
oh well anyways guys we'll Qyburn
creates some kind of a weapon to defeat
the Dragons well I think you better
because they aren't going to be able to
stop them with what they currently have
I know Qyburn can do some medical
engineering but I don't know if he can
do any kind of mechanical engineering I
think it's possible that he can think of
something to take them down so I won't
rule this out I think someone is going
to have to think of something if they
want to make this a fair fight I think
you better make his own damn dragon
binder or something like that
next it says Davos Centurion return to
dragonstone McKendree and they tell
Daenerys that Cersei won't surrender
ginjury tells John he knew arya so john
tells him that she is in Winterfell for
some reason I think this mission that
Davos in Tyrion took is to get ginjury
and ginjury only I don't think they went
there to talk to Jamie the timeline
doesn't make sense for Jaime and Bronn
to be in King's Landing during this and
I kind of feel like John and Daenerys
send them to get ginjury specifically
Tyrion knows King's Landing better than
anybody in Davos was a smuggler so they
are a perfect team to get in and out of
King's Landing quickly with ginjury who
I think is going to come into play as
the season goes on which I do have a
theory about that I will be releasing
this week but again these are all just
my opinions in the last scene is with
John and Davos they come up with a plan
to get Danny's forces north so they
decide to capture a white basing this
strictly off the photos and reports I
have seen so far I feel that something
along these lines is definitely going to
take place we can see here that Jon and
company are leaving Dragonstone and it
doesn't appear as if they are leaving
with any of Danny's men so it is
entirely plausible that she is not ready
to help in the north just yet so could
they be going to capture a white to
prove to her about the threat sure I
guess
but I think it would be easier for Dany
to ride on and rogue on and have her
other two dragons fly alongside her as
she goes and just takes a look for
herself she wouldn't have to get off the
dragon and being up that high in the sky
she could see them from a good distance
away without too much risk but I guess
that wouldn't be very exciting
television would it it would be a hell
of a lot more tense sending a group of
popular characters north to the most
dangerous place in the world with the
lack of manpower and a lack of weapons
to go behind the lines of the greatest
enemy of all time and capture one of
their men in an attempt to get back
South safely with the prison are fully
attacked that is much better television
so I think they may do something crazy
like this and from the look of the set
and from the reports it sounds like this
is actually going to happen most of you
already know
this but their set is already built with
a frozen lake and they have already cast
300 extras to play as whites in torment
benjin the Hound Jorah are all going to
be there for this scene too just like
the original league said so to me it
seems like that is exactly what's taking
place and until I hear otherwise that's
what I'm going to go with so it does
appear that most of this episode is
either taking place or looking like it
could be taking place there were only a
few minor things in here that I had
issue with but overall it seems to be on
the right track